ho trovato il sito della vita si chiama
jester rimette delle zone di google maps
e tu devi indovinare quali di queste
zone di quanti in queste zone ti trovi
tipo ti mette in una via alla cazzo di
cane tipo questa legge devi indovinare
dove trafficate incredibile ma dai
ragazzi questo è il primo round per
adesso indoviniamo dove siamo non ne ho
la più pallida idea perché mi chiama
strada in mezzo al nulla accadrà europa
dell'est sesia caso nel gas era in
finlandia dove abbiamo messo in in
ungheria non ci sono andato vicino un
extra a foglia trova in una città almeno
una città che palle non carte quel
castello lì e ti posso andare avanti a
non sono richiamanti mi chiedo la chiama
la prima città porca [ __ ] magari a 300
km da dall'autobus
cerchiamo di capire l'autobus fermi
tutti alla malga d'accusa data lega la
targa del [ __ ] madonna cestra grand
hotel calaf charaf calafrica bomba a
langata accusa mi sembra una roba tipo
brasiliana non so netgear
argentino dai prof sì però porca di una
trovai a me una città ragazzi c'è un
cartello grazie di gesù
fermi tutti zitti zitti che volevo fare
dobbiamo fare due chiacchiere ma che
cazzo censura di cartelli ma che
problema c'è il cartello scusami 2
difendere gli spezia e norvegia tutta la
vita zitti zitti norvegia ma devo
indovinare precisamente il punto del
amber che può essere la gamba fosse
usare un ruolo di play norvegia a caso
così bot
mccann un canale giusto della norvegia
non era vicino per attuate vender tua
sorella ad wenner e non era vicino
perché dall'altra parte della norvegia
per ora ho azzeccato lo stato
incredibile ma [ __ ] l'afc aveva i
problemi nel cercare là non lo so canada
avete dei problemi nel cercare nel
mettermi nelle città ho sparato a cazzo
ed era 700 km cioè migliaia era più
vicino né con una norvegia di prima
sparato a caso questa italia questa
italia fermi tutti i siti vestita ho
studiato un bel cartello questo è il
diritto di precedenza su strade
secondarie questa non è milano non è
mila citroen non è milano scemi in the
school and le fans de nard sankara detto
vicino a santa messa
ma teme che anche sempre in francia non
capivo 300 chilometri orari
record per ora ha un famoso places c'è
anche famos places fighissima la
facciamo quello dei primi posti famose
questo è il vaticano subito lo conosco e
il vaticano
questo mio zio salve signora benvenuto
in un fitto di forlì gente
roma fiumicino fregene vaticano in
teoria dovrebbe essere facendosi magari
qui ma torno a 320 metri 220 porca vacca
era qui ma secondo te io se il passeggio
sopra il tetto so dove cazzo sono per
chi mi hai preso prezzi o uditore zio
c'era dall'altro devo sapere 2000 sono
dall'alto sembra inghilterra larga a
prima di primo avviso non sono bassi con
fatica sono stato suo clan tetto di sta
roba fare google maps ma ci avete una
vita visit panoramic porca vacca st
francia che palle ma è un software e
parigi lo so e la porcata che sono stato
sono stato assure al power ha fatto un
time lapse su questo palo ve lo giuro è
sulla collina di puttan le putain
l'esame del salvatore questo questo e
questo per questo qui sono stato a
parigi grado aprile porta che culo che
pure è l'aver mi porti di culo supporti
di turno anche qua ci sono stato sempre
l'anno scorso era che sarà fermata dei
treni
se non sbaglio mica ragazzo tutto sotto
stato ovunque lo stato poi non so dove
di me va beh mica tutta acqua porca
[ __ ] non so dove c'è la stazione
ecco qua ponte degli scalzi mi scusi lei
che se queste smith es
c'è anche un mito fuori che cazzo
fotografi cinese in mezzo all'acqua che
so qui il ponte dove è quello che sarà
più o meno qui ma non come 200 metri si
vabbè ma mica dai dall'altra da dopo
sephora plein extrav va bene così
ragazzi baraja già michela il
famosissimo camion trafic famosissimo
cazzo di posti di cestini cosa c'è di
famosi a il camion non aiutava
tantissimo
ve lo posso assicurarti ai signori sono
stato anche qui mi che incredibile su
cinque posti quattro li ho visitati
della sagrada famiglia adesso è giusto
mamma mia quanta cultura in sol uomo
quanta uno sbaglio faccia prima di merda
l'intervento è che se la sagrada
famiglia non so neanche dove barcellona
pensate avere un cazzo scommesso ecco
qua devo metterci anche l'angolo della
strada proprio che sono sei contento
sagrada famiglia la guardi di qua quindi
l'angolo dovrebbe essere l'angolo a
parte questo se il parco è questo la
sagrada famiglia dovrebbe essere in
teoria qua intera no cazzo all'altro
angolo the sfiga nora quello prost
ragazzi era quello possono va bene per
sapere ho fatto un sacco di punti raga
mi chiamo la continua seccato in pieno
ragazzi riparano un'altra sempre con i
posti famosi perché è fighissimo prove
rivedere dico questo
by ap il porca [ __ ]
mi chiamo so perché non mi viene in
mente la lezione lo so dove e in cile
con che nell america del sud sicuro zero
punti da zero era in perù va bene più o
meno cosa che era il mais ufficio eccomi
canoni 20
niente porca vacca dei ragazzi in essere
cos'è sta roba che cazzo sono le mura
dell'attacco dei giganti queste questo
in spagna ma non è già lì dove sia
quindi sparo a caso da 238 km è già
qualcosa
peggio tra piece col sembra un sempre al
nome di una di quelle poltrone leli che
ha quindi è in svezia prescindere poi
anche tutto blu e gialli svezia zitti
zitti svezia 2 giallo intenso è uniche
all'aperto non lo so i badge zitti tutti
che in discesa a ostersund manco bugar
dov'era il già in danimarca porca vacca
in danimarca ma cos'è sta roba schedate
che non lo so non conosco legoland maga
ragazzi l'ultima della partita vediamo
noi siamo questa non è l'italia ma che
il posto famoso dovrebbe essere spiega
questo esami legoland che cazzo di posto
è ma chi lo conosce questo e justin
bieber in bermuda ma cosa ma qualcuno
che mi spiega che il posto è per
cortesia costo sta tentando di forzare
un cancello toghe e cado è beccato i
ladri corali il ladro guarda tutto tutto
tutto che si fa i cazzi suoi come se
nessuno potesse guardare la pena si
allontanano tech che ci provano e ladro
roncolo da quattro soldi
volevi entrarci devono che si stende
sexy questi sono i barboni
salita palacio era gay in spagna però
non so dove cazzo sia salamanca 451 ti
dov'era granata maledizione granata e al
parco palacio de carlos quinto che ne so
il nostro se non sapevamo se avremmo si
è studiato morboso l'avevo ragazzi basta
fratello è un gioco fico farò
sicuramente un altro episodio di sta
roba bellissimo quindi ragazzi con
prodotti episodio come al solito se vi
piace sono certamente mi piace anche ma
diciamo solo il dominio totale notizia
ci sono e si rischia temi ci dividiamo
le pulsioni dai ragazzi
[Musica]